face it Star Wars shouldn't have worked
there was a science fiction fairytale
made when Hollywood was cranking out
gritty character driven dramas it
starred a handful of unknown actors and
a man in a fur suit
it begins with 20 minutes of robots
wandering through a desert the main
villain of the original trilogy is a
space wizard that sounds like a disaster
not the beginning of a multi-billion
dollar franchise yet despite all odds
star wars didn't just clean up at the
box office it literally reinvented the
entire Hollywood machine and it came so
close to never happening here's why
flash of genius Star Wars Hidden Springs
fully formed from George Lucas's head in
fact if Lucas had his way he would have
made an entirely different movie as a
child
Lucas loved the old Flash Gordon serials
when he what happened to dear dr. Jack
after Lucas's debut the cold and
lifeless science fiction thriller thx
1-1 3-8 failed to excite audiences and
critics Lucas wanted to make something
with more hearts so he sought the rights
to make a new Flash Gordon film but
Lucas ultimately couldn't seal the deal
with King's beach' syndicate which
published Alex Raymond's original comic
strip and owned the rights to the
character so fortunately for Star Wars
fans he decided to invent his own Flash
Gordon like saga my rocket fleet at once
will go to the sky city of Multan and
kick you money get less studio
resistance while thx 1-1 3-8 was a flop
Lucas's second feature American Graffiti
was one of the most profitable movies of
all time and a Best Picture nominee I'd
like to write around me for
I can't avoid them Universal Pictures
executives were delighted at the film
success and wanted more
Lucas however had his heart set on Star
Wars and submitted a 12 page outline for
the flick the studio passed and many of
Lucas's friends and colleagues agreed
encouraging Lucas to make a deeper film
more grounded and serious but Lucas
wouldn't listen
sci-fi dry spell Universal is in the
only studio that passed on Star Wars
United Artists and Disney said no to
arguing that science fiction wasn't
popular and wouldn't sell after all a
Star Wars producer Gary Kurtz noted to
IGN it took seven years for 1968 2001 a
Space Odyssey to turn a profit and the
last big space opera 1956 is Forbidden
Planet was almost twenty years old when
Lucas was pitching Star Wars William O
lemon contraption how to take a carrot
will you quiet please
I am analyzing when Lucas tried to
explain to the studio's of Star Wars was
more fun to seed in science fiction the
debate was lost on 20th Century Fox
President Alan Ladd jr. who just wanted
Lucas period each I don't understand
this but I loved American Graffiti in
whatever you do is okay with me so in
1973
Lucas finally inked a deal to write and
direct Star Wars for Fox financial woes
he is one of Star Wars as biggest
secrets it was not an expensive film
well Star Wars established a template
for the expensive Hollywood blockbuster
its initial budget was relatively tiny
Fox gave Lucas and his crew just eight
million dollars but unfortunately that
wasn't quite enough when he asked for
more
Fox shut down pre-production and forced
the team to come up with a new budget
which came out to about 10 million
dollars
Lucas was forced to scrap a number of
scenes including Han Solo's
confrontation with Jabba the Hutt's
later controversially added via CGI to
the special edition of the film trouble
in Tunisia Tatooine Luke Skywalker's
home planet was originally supposed to
be a jungle but
Luke has changed it to a desert planet
after a location scout in the
Philippines irritated a skin
well tattooing twin suns of setting over
the dunes is one of the most iconic
images and a franchise full of iconic
images Tunisia isn't the most hospitable
environment for filmmaking and the
production fell behind immediately
allegedly the Sun didn't mix well with
the cameras damaging lots of expensive
equipment when storms ravaged the sets
and are through d2 controls didn't work
particularly well either as the sand
interfered with the remote radio signals
and then there was the weather on the
second day of shooting a freak rainstorm
with the first winter rain that the area
had gotten in 50 years made filming
practically impossible delays almost
spelled doom
thanks for the problems in Tunisia star
wars was behind schedule by the time the
crew moved to England unfortunately
things didn't get much better union
rules severely limited when the cast and
crew could work and it didn't help that
Lucas was still tweaking the script
while filming all that Lucas had to fire
the film's original editor meaning an
hour's worth of footage had to be recut
filming began in March 1976 by July
Lucas was 15 days behind schedule
Fox issued an ultimatum Lucas had to
finish the film in a week or the studio
was going to pull the plug the studio
almost buried it while an early
screening for studio executives went
well folks wasn't sure how to sell Star
Wars to the public so they didn't
instead the studio put its marketing
muscle behind the other side of midnight
which was based on a best-selling novel
and had a built-in audience meanwhile
theater owners thought that Star Wars
was a kiddy movie and didn't want to
screen it so in order to boost
circulation Fox fourth theater chains
had wanted the other side of midnight to
book Star Wars as well as Star Wars
broke record after record for both
attendance and the box office returns
Fox expanded into as many markets as
possible by September Star Wars was in
1,100 theaters an unheard-of number at
the time and its first theatrical run
lasted for over a year by then it was
clear despite the odds star
was was ahead and Hollywood would never
be the same
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]